hi I'm date Mike nice to meet me how do
you like your eggs in the morning
[Music]
[Applause]
Amy Santiago
you have made me the happiest man on
Earth
I spent one whole dollar on this ring
will you go on the worst date ever with
me you have to say yes
yes she said
thank you she said yes for you
[Music]
ah
Amy Santiago date time time to date
Peralta this outfit is ridiculous Chop
Chop there's plenty of embarrassing to
do in only a few hours to do it in
happy oh yeah you look like every girl
at every bot Mitzvah I ever had a crush
on let's see the bow
just like Jenny gildenhorn why do I wish
you had braces should we get you braces
no that's too much here I come
nice shorts thank you believe it or not
they were not very expensive I'm sorry
that I can't stay but I have a terrible
night planned for Amy first up is the
mall photo studio where we'll take our
official date portrait the picture will
be the two of us playing one saxophone
then some peel and eat shrimp for dinner
at a dangerously cheap seafood
restaurant and then I've contracted a
youth choir to serenade us
yes
[Music]
channel that passion into the dance
so you never told me where you're from
I'm from Pawnee keep still please
what kind of music do you like can I
answer that sure keep still
very important that you keep still at
this moment Leslie I've told you that a
thousand times
do you ever break your arm you can
answer that here I'll turn it off one
time I was on my bike and
bike and I'm surprised you can see that
it was like three years ago
you never had any kids right Leslie
you've got a great oven okay
time to go got ample room in there
honestly if you wanted to you could go
triplets right off the bat Leslie you
got a big industrial sized oven so we're
done right well
apparently
Michael Scott is on a date
and that
that's my friend changes everything
oh yeah you told me about him yeah oh
boy yeah he's all right hey Michael
where have you been
hey you're supposed to hit the white
ball first buddy
can I talk to you for a second mm-hmm
everything okay are you wearing a hat
now guys come on I'm on a date let me do
my thing hey guys guys guys excuse
everyone watch this ready
what are you doing I'm trying to not
understand with my top likely not to do
this
yeah
oh wow that was close I would say I kind
of have an unfair Advantage because I
watch reality dating shows like Hawk and
I learn I absorb information from the
strategies of the winners and the losers
actually I probably learned more from
the losers
had done a background check on me she
you had to print it out no yeah and she
was asking me about stuff line by line
while we were having dinner
what's going on we are doing worst first
dates oh my God I win
okay it was minor league hockey game he
brought his brother and when I went to
the bathroom the game ended and they
forgot about me okay that's a joke no
they had to come back for me
wait what was this
um
it was not that long ago wait not Roy
say it's not your fiance
hahaha
I always knew Pam has refused to go to
sports games with Roy
but I never knew why
interesting
hi Dave you're late and I can see your
nipples through your dress what no
really in nursing school we took a psych
course on how to treat phobias with a
method called exposure therapy
so like if you were afraid of snakes
they would immerse you in a tank of
snakes
so I am going to immerse Leslie in a
tank of bad date you're 20 minutes late
I almost left okay well I was uh
dropping my niece off what's your
niece's name torpal what I don't know
that's not a name I don't have an ease
my niece's name is Stephanie stop lying
hey look there's bread you want
something oh no oh I got flowers in your
suit I'm so sorry um just I have to go
to the um
whiz Palace you know Dave the the place
where you
you know the toilet thing
it's a bathroom it's called a bathroom
thank you very much
our suspect has straight brown hair
she is wearing blue jeans and a black
top
so
Behold our Bachelorette
give her a 10 for looks and a three for
her ability to describe herself
hello my lady
Michael
ah
are you Michael Scott
so Michael what oh I'm sorry I'm I'm
supposed to be meeting someone named
Michael oh that's not yeah Michael
Michael
large hot chocolate with caramel and
shot of peppermint
so you get the rent checks every month
and
what happens next what
you're asking me what I
do with the checks that people write to
me
just making conversation why is this
hard to meet people I you know it's uh
all I want is somebody nice and sweet
and someone I can talk to and share an
experience with you know
why is it so hard for people like us
you want to see what I walked out on
this is going to blow your mind look at
that
she's beautiful yeah yeah and you can't
see her whole body down here she did a
boob job just
she was just crazy smart and really
manipulative and I don't know
I'm gonna head out
oh okay well
um I enjoyed this conversation
it was very nice
it was like talking to
the sweet old lady on the bus
incredibly rude
now you ruined it
two more questions for you Anne what if
he shows up with another woman what if
one of my sleeves catches on fire and it
spreads rapidly What If instead of tic
tacs I accidentally pop a couple of
Ambien and I have to keep punching my
leg to stay awake those are all insane
hypotheticals and I promise you they
won't happen
they have happened
all of these have happened to me
uh no there's more one time I
accidentally drank an entire bottle of
vinegar I thought it was terrible wine
once I went out with a guy who wore 3D
glasses the entire evening oh one time I
rode in the sidecar on a guy's
motorcycle and the side card attached
and went down to fly the stairs another
time I went to a really boring movie
with a guy and while I was asleep he
tried to pull out one of my teeth
I literally woke up with his hand in my
mouth
we went out a couple times after that
then it got weird